One of the most surprising aspects about one
of the saddest of all human possibilities,
suicide, is that the suicide rate goes up
markedly the richer and more developed a society
becomes. We might expect suicide rates to
vary across time and place, but not to increase
alongside developments in wealth, comfort
and security. That we should be unwittingly
creating nations in which more of us end up
killing ourselves at our own hands appears
to negate the whole purpose of economic growth.
Nevertheless, the disturbing connection was
first conclusively identified towards the
end of the 19th century by the leading French
sociologist, Emile Durkheim – and has continued
to be noted ever since. The suicide rate of
an undeveloped country like the Democratic
Republic of the Congo is a fraction of the
rate in a developed nation like South Korea.
The crucial factor behind people’s decision
to end their lives is not really wealth or
poverty. As Durkheim discovered, it is the
extent to which the surrounding culture ascribes
responsibility for failure to individuals
or else maintains a faith that poor luck,
or divine intervention is to blame instead.
It so happens that as societies become modern
and industrialised, they very frequently give
up their beliefs in demons and gods and start
instead to trust in a meritocratic, individualistic
philosophy that suggests to people that their
fate is always in their own hands. This may
sound generous but it carries an immense psychological
burden, for it means that – when failures
occur – the individual is held entirely
responsible for them. Reversals start to seem
like a horrendous judgement on one’s worth
and a public humiliation from which there
may, at the extreme, seem no escape other
than through annihilation.
There are two big cultural ideas that may help to
mitigate the pressures upon us: Luck and Tragedy.
To believe in Luck is accurately to observe
that merit and success are in fact never reliably
aligned; one may be a fool and win – or
a virtuous person and fail. If we fully internalise
and widely share the notion of luck, then
the shame of failure will be greatly reduced
and our agony along with it. We will be able
to admit, publically and to ourselves, that
decent people can fail in their outward circumstances
and, therefore, that professional success
isn’t the only, or even, the crucial marker
of the merit of human beings.A Tragedy, as
it originated in Ancient Greece, is the story
of a capable and intelligent person who happens
to make a small mistake – which, however,
leads to appalling consequences. The point
of presenting such stories in very public
ways (at Greek festivals the entire community
had to attend) was to continually renew acquaintance
with a hugely important idea: that one can
be a likable, even admirable person, and end
up in an utterly desperate situation. Tragedy
is the careful telling of how disaster can
come into the lives of people like (or even
a bit nicer) than us. They – and hence we
– are always deserving of compassion rather
than contempt. Durkheim knew that it is not
prosperity by itself that increases the suicide
rate, the toxic element is an unwittingly
cruel culture that assigns a high burden of
responsibility to us, while seeming to deny
the truth that chance and tragedy will of
course always continue to affect our destinies.
The real solution to a high suicide rate lies
in an unexpected place: an ideology that firmly
reminds us that we are never the sole authors
of our destinies.  and therfore should neither panic nor celebrate when we win or loose.
We publish new thought provoking films every week.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel and take a look at more of what we have to offer at the link on your screen now.